seit 20 jahren lenkt er die geschicke
russlands wladimir putin sein name steht
für skrupellosigkeit killerkommandos und
schrecken putin verleibte sich die krim
ein die stabilisierte die ost ukraine
lässt in syrien krankenhäuser und
schulen bombardieren doch die geschichte
des wladimir putins sie ist auch mit
deutschland verbunden
in dresden spezielle putin ab 1985 als
ausland spion des gefürchteten kgb war
deutsche agenten an und lebte in diesen
plattenbau zum ersten mal konnte bild
nie in die ehemalige wohnung des
russischen präsidenten peter jörg
hofmann lebt hier seit 1991 den
schlüssel überreichte damals noch der
vormieter wladimir putin
ich hatte im januar einen vorgehen
getroffen kann ist aber dann doch machen
die konzerne
damals wusste ich an die wehr ist habe
ich ihn ja nicht mehr sehr kurze
unterredung auch seine frau und die
tochter und die waren alles sehr
freundlich wollen ja mal wird um merken
mehrfach mit denen gesprochen und waren
ganz ganz blöder als putins seite damals
umgerechnet 94 mark miete für die 63
quadratmeter große wohnung im vierten
stock
hier kamen 1986 auch tochter katharina
zur welt
das war relativ alles also einfach
eingerichtet auch ein kreuzer dunkle
möbel die dunkles große schlafzimmer
eine große schrank wald aber es war
keine ddr schrankwand
ich vermute dass das erste heimat worden
und so die möbel im gesamten haus lebten
damals zahlreiche stasi größen mit
besonderen sicherheitsvorkehrungen was
ich noch weiß im dritten stock bis in
anfang der 90er jahre aber eine sirene
angebracht und die könnten hier alarm
auslösen wenn die sirene ging gegen die
haus lichter aus und dann war unten
durch die keller noch eingang der unter
dem fuß weg runter ging vermutlich zu
angelika sträuße
vor wenigen wochen klingelte plötzlich
putins erzfeind an der tür alexej
nawalny der arbeitete damals in seiner
video dokumentation und enthüllt später
mehr als eine milliarde euro habe
wladimir putin über seine dubiosen
geheimdienstkontakte in eine trotz villa
gesteckt wohnfläche mehr als 17.000
quadratmeter putins palast am schwarzen
meer hat mit dem dresdener plattenbau
von damals nichts mehr gemein
vitali er kauft man fühlt sich hier
trotzdem wohl und will bleiben
in putins agenten wohnungen in der
dresdener neustadt zum ersten mal
überhaupt dürfte ein journalist in diese
wohnung rein und das war unser kollege
jürgen helfricht und er ist uns jetzt
auch zugeschaltet sag uns du bist jetzt
gerade in dieser wohnsiedlung wir haben
auch den trotz palast gesehen denen sich
putin gebaut haben soll
ich nehme mal an dort ist die gegend
eine etwas andere beschreibung später
einmal hallo aus dresden wir stehen
jetzt jeder direkt vor dem haus rhader
straße 101 putin von 1985 bis 1991
gewohnt hat das ist eine typische ddr
plattenbau siedlung also in dem alten
charme der ddr sehr einfach gehalten
dieses haus im inneren das sind ganz
normale treppenaufgänge kleine zimmer es
riecht ein bisschen nach politologie um
das ist von einer exklusivität oder
einem luxus überhaupt nichts zu spüren
seit 20 jahren lebt man dort eigentlich
ein bewusste was das für da in dieser
wohnung mal für einen vermieter gab und
wie spricht man darüber also den leuten
ist das schon bewusst das hängt auch
damit zusammen dass russische
reisegruppen hier regelmäßig vor den
türen halten vermieter der sich bisher
nie dazu geäußert hat sagte das ist
schon manchmal ganz schön lästig sind
sie glauben dass hier ein putin museum
wäre und erwarten dass sie eintritt
zahlen und in die wohnung dürfen und
quasi wie durch heiligen räume geführt
werden das ist absolut nicht der fall
die menschen sind ja dann eher etwas
genervt jetzt haben wir ja
seit gestern kennen wir diese bilder aus
diesem trotz palast am schwarzmeer das
sieht ja hinter dir ein bisschen anders
aus nur waren das natürlich auch
zugegebenermaßen bisschen andere zeiten
für den heutigen präsidenten
trotzdem fragt man sich warum
ausgerechnet da hast du dazu eine
erklärung warum in so einem plattenbau
ja es gibt eine ganz einfache erklärung
hier in der nähe war die
bezirksverwaltung staatssicherheit mit
ihren 3500 mitarbeitern zu ddr-zeiten
und putin hat er als eine kgb das sind
ua nur 150 meter entfernt von der
staatssicherheit und der wurde deshalb
auch im vierten stock dieses straffe
wohnblock ist ein quartier
wir waren also nur stasi mitarbeit und
paletten heute untergebracht und sie
müssen sie hier diesen
geheimdienstlichen dingen natürlich
unterwerfen aber ein riesiges misstrauen
unter den reichen bewohnern
es gibt wohl wieder die leute begeistert
haben aber heute kein einziger dieser
ehemals im stasi hauptamtlichen
stasi-mitarbeiter in diesem haus sind
längst alle ausgeflogen
jetzt haben wir die bilder die du uns
mitgebracht hast eben im beitrag gesehen
aber beschreibt uns einmal wie fühlt es
sich dort an wenn man dort drinnen ist
in der früheren wohnung von putin was
hat man dafür ja also nach 30 jahren ist
natürlich kein besonderes mehr zu spüren
aber wenn man sich überlegt er war
natürlich in dieser wendezeit auch wo
also das russische kommunistische reich
zusammenbrach die ddr zusammenbrach und
man kann sich da schon ein bisschen
überlegen wie die leute auch von ängsten
geprägt waren das war ja ein paar fall
des gesamten kommunistischen systems auf
der welt und wenn man durch diese engen
kleine räume geht dann kann man sich
schon vorstellen sowie ausgebildet und
gibt es dort haben über ihre eigene
zukunft putin wo es bedarf einiger zeit
ja überhaupt nicht was ihm werden soll
der geheimdienst kgb auch zusammen und
es hat mich ein bisschen erinnert mehr
erzählte der bewohner der heutige der
seit 30 jahren als quasi auf dem fuß die
schlüssel in die hand gedrückt bekam das
an den grenzen überall kleine materie
oscars waren als abziehbilder als der
eindruck die hat dann natürlich entfernt
hat und ich war vor einiger zeit in
moskau und werden
diese matroschkas verkauft mittlerweile
mit dem porträt auch von putin
also da und man sich dann doch wie sich
die welt entwickelt hat hier trägt unser
reporter der exklusiv in der früheren
wohnung von vladimir putin in dresden
war ganz herzlichen dank für diesen
bericht ganz herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzung ihre geschichte
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren